tout blanchemaison pourquoi l'article et
il l'objet de tant de convoitises
d'abord l'article présente une
particularité c'est que il n'y a pas de
traité international qui régissent le
statut de l'arctique alors qu'il y en a
pour l'antarctique
et c'est parce qu'il ya une différence
fondamentale c'est antarctique c'est un
continent des montagnes qui émerge du
fond de la mer alors que l'article ça
n'est pas le cas c'est une banquise qui
flotte sur l'océan et la deuxième raison
c'est que il y a des richesses
considérables dans le sous-sol de
l'arctique et que le réchauffement
climatique fait que l'exploitation si
richesse devient plus facile
c'est à dire moins coûteux la troisième
raison c'est que les grands sont en face
à face autour de l'arctique puisqu'il ya
d'un côté la très grande façade nord de
la russie
et puis de l'autre côté il ya l'alaska
et le canada + 5 autres pays d'europe du
nord qui sont les voisins du cercle
polaire et qui par conséquent sont
riverains de l'océan arctique
alors tous ont des intérêts particuliers
et certains d'entre eux évidemment ont
aussi souhaité étendre leur zone
économique exclusive puisque comme il
n'ya pas de prêter régissant ce
continent qui n'existent pas eh bien
c'est le droit de la mer qui s'applique
le traité sur le droit de la mer est en
vigueur depuis 1992 et qui permet aux
aux états d'étendre leurs zones
économiques exclusives à 200 milles
marins de la côte
d'ailleurs 350 km 15 km 15 milles marins
pardon la mer territoriale 350
kilomètres la zone économique exclusive
et quand lorsque deux zones économiques
exclusives viennent en contradiction et
bien on s'assoit et on négocie
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans un certain
nombre de cas mais pas dans tous les cas
dans l'arctique et par conséquent il y à
là avec des bases militaires
du côté russe comme du côté
américain un enjeu important qui est un
enjeu global avec pour tout le monde
l'enjeu de la liberté de circulation
dans les mers et encore une fois avec le
réchauffement climatique
l'ouverture de la route du nord qui fait
que l'europe peut être rallier par
bateau à l'asie en une durée de temps
beaucoup au moins longue qu'en passant
par le canal de suez et par conséquent
un certain nombre de pays veulent se
positionner sur cette route y compris
d'ailleurs la chine qui n'a pas de
façade sur l'océan arctique mais qui
considère qu'elle a un intérêt direct à
ce qui se passe dans l'océan arctique et
qui construit d'ailleurs des brise
glaces pour exporter sa flotte
quelles sont les revendications des pays
voisins
alors d'abord la norvège très sagement a
conclu un accord avec la russie en 2010
pour régler tous les problèmes de
délimitation de zones maritimes zone
économique exclusive zones de pêche
la norvège est un cas un peu particulier
parce que très au nord
elle possède un archipel qui s'appelle
des salles baard eker archipel
absolument stratégique dans la position
il se trouve et qu'elle tenait à garder
une zone de pêche autour de cet archipel
et puis d'en garder le contrôle un
accord est intervenu avec la russie et
par conséquent la norvège maintenant n'a
plus de revendications particulières
la russie a déposé il ya quelques années
un dossier auprès de l' agence de l'onu
qui s'occupe de l'application du traité
sur le droit de la mer pour expliquer
que une épine sous-marine qu'on appelle
la dorsale de lomonosov parts et
perpendiculairement à la côte de sibérie
vers le pôle nord et que par conséquent
cette épine dorsale de donner droit à la
russie un plateau continental allant au
delà de la zone des 200 milles dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
donc c'est celle de s'être cette demande
a fait l'objet d'une instruction qui n'a
pas toujours
n'ont pas encore débouché en 2007
d'ailleurs la russie a monté une
expédition au pôle nord avec le célèbre
spécialiste des pôles ce schilling a
rohff et cette expédition s'est illustré
entre autres en envoyant un sous-marin
planté un drapeau sous sur le exactement
alors à l'endroit où il est convenu de
considérer que c'est le pôle le pôle
étant à 4000 mètres sous le niveau de la
mer alors il ya d'autres revendications
le danemark a des revendications au nom
du groenland puisque c'est le danemark
qui administre le groenland la la le
canada et les états unis
ils n'ont pas encore affiché le traité
sera de la mer ont également des rangs
des ratifications au titre de
l'extension de leurs plateaux
territoriales donc ça ce sont les
revendications juridique mais qui
s'accompagne naturellement de conception
un petit peu différente s'ils ont la
liberté de navigation dans toute cette
zone puisque cette zone en réalité fait
partie de la route mère lorsqu'elle ne
venait pas dans une dans une zone
économique exclusive et que la
navigation est totalement libre que les
sous-marins probablement ils circulent
en toute liberté jeudi sous marins
indiens évidemment question stratégique
club blanchemaison lors de ce sommet
anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov vont
s'entretenir lors d'une réunion
d'anticipation à la rencontre byden
poutine prévue au mois de juin
de quoi vont ils bien pouvoir parler
alors il ya deux schémas pour la
rencontre lavrov desquels il ya le
schéma conflictuel dans le fondre
monsieur lavrov a donné l'exemple avec
monsieur borel avec le représentant de
l'union européenne et puis dont monsieur
clint kent a donné l'exemple avec le miz
affaires étrangères chinois là je pense
que ce ne sera pas le cas je pense que
monsieur plis qu'elle veut préparer
sérieusement avec monsieur lavrov
la rencontre entre le président poutine
et le président joe biden
les enjeux sont évidemment considérable
et il ya donc là
encore encore deux autres hypothèques à
lever est ce que on cherchera à discuter
d'abord des sujets sur lesquels on peut
trouver un accord
ou est-ce qu'on cherchera surtout à
disputer les sujets qui fâchent
je me fâche on les connaît c'est des
droits de l'homme c'est la vanille c'est
la biélorussie éventuellement l'ukraine
il faudra bien en parler mais on peut
aussi parler de sujets sur lesquels la
russie et les etats unis ont un intérêt
commun
d'abord il ya tous les sujets
stratégiques puisque ça fait pas par
hasard que joe biden a prolongé dès son
arrivée à la maison blanche pour cinq
ans le traité new start qui limite le
nombre d'ogives nucléaires et le nombre
de missiles de fusées intercontinentales
pour les lancer
par contre il semble pas que les etats
unis soient intéressés à revenir ou à
ressusciter le traité sur les armes
nucléaires intermédiaires qui a été
dénoncé par monsieur trump hui à la
suite parlée par les russes
et aujourd'hui on n'entend qu'eux il en
va de même pour le traiter à ciel ouvert
ces traités avait un intérêt c'est
qu'ils sont tous
ils contiennent tous un élément de des
changes de surveillance et que dans le
fond pour créer de la confiance entre
des rivaux stratégie il faut
certainement prévoir des mesures de
surveillance et peut-être que c'est un
sujet que monsieur blinken et monsieur
lavrov évoqueront tout à l'heure alors
il ya beaucoup d'autres sujets qui
peuvent être évoqués bien entendu le
réchauffement climatique
ça paraît banal mais c'est quand même
tout à fait vitale d'autant plus que
dans le nord de la russie
le permafrost est en train de fondre que
ça met en péril un certain nombre
d'infrastructures y compris des gazoducs
et que en revanche par contre ça
permettra sans doute à la russie
d'étendre sa zone cultivable et par
conséquent sa production agricole dans
les 25 ans qui viennent tout ceci tous
sur tous ces sujets une coopération est
possible ce ne sont pas des sujets
conflictuels la cybersécurité
c'est un autre sujet qui fait beaucoup
parler mais après tout d'un côté comme
de l'autre on a peut-être besoin d'avoir
des codes communs des grilles de lecture
qu'il fasse que l'on ne puisse pas
s'accuser de n'importe quelle attaque et
complice essayer d'établir un minimum de
cyber sécurité dans le monde
surtout qu'actuellement en effet des
opérateurs privés peuvent remonter des
prêts facilement des offensives et les
actions très destructive
alors on verra ce que ce que ça oui
pardonnez moi je voulais pas vous couper
la chique aussi brutalement mon arrivée
à la à la fin de cette heure merci en
tout cas on a compris le débat et on
verra effectivement à ce qu'il en
ressortira de ces sujets avec cette
réunion entre les deux hommes ce soir
merci à vous